it's  interesting i was going to give you uh  three books uh  i i noted the accent when i met you but  i didn't know exactly where you're from  but the the other book i was going to  say is dostoevsky's crime and punishment  and i mean i've always wanted to go to  saint pete's uh  just to sort of see with my own eyes  what the word pictures that uh  dostoevsky created  in a crime and punishment and you know i  love others of this stuff  too the brothers care myself and so  forth but crime and punishment i first  read  in high school as a junior or senior and  it is a  deep and profound uh meditation  on uh the the both the meaning and the  measure  of our lives and uh uh  dostoevsky uh obviously in in  in conversation with other uh thinkers  um uh really gets at the  uh the the crux of  a fundamental philosophical problem what  does it mean to be a human being  and and  for that crime and punishment captured  me as a teenager and that's another text  that i returned to uh often  you